ومن سبيكر
اول امراه تتراس مجلس النواب الامريكي
[تصفيق]
2003 ورئيسه للمجلس على فترتين منفصلتين
واحتلت الموقع الثالثه في هرم السلطه
السياسيه في عهد اربعه رؤساء
عرفت بروسي بصرامتها وفرضها لانضباط
الحزبيه تحت قيادتها مرر الكونجرس قانون
الرعايه الصحيه الميسره الذي عرف بعبامكار
واداره التناقضات الداخليه مع صعود اليسار
داخل الحزب الديمقراطي
ومع قرارها التنحيه عن زعامه الحزب في
الكونغرس تثار واسئله عن التحديات
والمهمات التي ستواجه الجيل الجديد
على المستوى القومي ينبغي التعامل مع سعيد
رمل العوده الى البيت الابيض وحقيقه ان
الجمهوريين يسيطرون على مجلس النواب اما
فيما يتعلق بالتعقيدات داخل الحزب
الديمقراطي فعليهم الحفاظ على وحده الحزب
نانسي
كبيره بسبب مده التي خدمتها ولانها حافظت
على علاقات جيده مع الجناحين التقدمي
والاكثر اعتدالا في الحزب تظل لمرحله
الاكثر واشكاليه في مسيره بيروس السياسيه
تلك التي ترافقت مع تولي ترامب سده
الرئاسه الخصومه طباعه العلاقه بين الرئيس
والزعيمه خصومه تعمقات مع اشراف بيلوسي
على محاكمتين برلمانيتين بحق ترامب
وبينهما
مؤيدين الاخيره مبنى الكونجرس اما قرار
بيلوسي التخلي عن مطرقه القياده فجاء بعد
انتزاع الجمهوريين مجلس النواب في
الانتخابات النصفيه الاخيره
وبصولي تداعيات الانقسامات السياسيه الى
عقررها من خلال الاعتداء الذي تعرض له
زوجها في منزلهما
في مرحله تاريخيه ويمهد ربما لمرحله قد
تدخل التاريخ بدورها مع صعود نجم النائب
حكيم جفريز خليفه لها وهو لها زعيم اسود
لاحد الحزبين في الكونغرس فدى منصور
الجزيره واشنطن